bonjour lima le cortège est donc bientôt
arriver à soupe en finale le sacré coeur
oui tout à fait un million nous sommes
un boulevard magenta nos comptes
direction tu sais quelques heures vous
l'avez dit donc cette manifestation à
qui est parti à 14h30 environ et qui
compte dans ses rangs plusieurs milliers
de personnes et davantage encore du côté
de fanions philippot si l'on en croit
les informations données par nos
collègues cela rejoint d'ailleurs à peu
près les estimations qui avaient été
près de parole les forces de l'ordre
savoir au moins dix mille personnes à
manifester a défilé dans la capitale
aujourd'hui on peut noter ainsi un
rebond de cette mobilisation depuis
environ une semaine à un jeu rappelle
que samedi dernier ils étaient 105
milles à manifester dans toute la france
en remonte de la manifestation de la
mobilisation donc que l'on peut
attribuer notamment sans doute à ses
propos du président de la république je
vous rappelle la phrase emmanuel macron
les non-vaccinés j'ai très envie de les
emmerder une phrase qui est encore très
présente dans les esprits des personnes
aujourd'hui qui manifestent dans ce
cortège des jeunes et bien entendu il ya
également l'actualité sanitaire vous
avez entendu estelle farges vous parlais
à l'instant du pass vaccinale qui est en
discussion au sénat et qui devrait
entrer en vigueur vraisemblablement
d'ici à la fin de la semaine prochaine
ou début mai une suivante et je vous
propose d'écouter certains des
manifestants à ces deux sujets
nous aussi on emmerde voilà la réponse
qu'on me donnera à mâcon ont leurs nerfs
d'aussi également ils respectent pas le
peuple reculer respectent pas les
citoyens je puis pouvoir prendre le
train j'ai pu pouvoir aller voir ma
famille comme je veux
les restos des bars et tout ça je m'en
fous un peu voilà mais surtout aller
voir les gens que j'aime il veut diviser
je pense qu'il veut diviser les français
et c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire
en fait s'envoler les prix sont un petit
peu d'être un peu beaucoup d'être des
prisonniers on a l'impression d'être
coupable alors qu'on n'a rien fait
on a l'impression d'être des pestiférés
alors qu'on n'est pas malade voilà c'est
comme un extrait c'est quand même
extrêmement grave je suis pas pour la
contrainte je suis plus dans l'emballage
que je veux comme je veux convaincre les
gens moi je juge je suis partisan de que
voilà que les gens se vaccine d'autant
plus les gens à risque voilà après après
maintenant je me suis contre
l'obligation voilà c'est surtout ça qui
me motive et autres sources de la
mobilisation aujourd'hui vous en avez
parlé emilie a bien sûr la désactivation
de ces nombreux pas salutaire si l'on en
croit les chiffres du ministère de la
santé ce sont environ 560 mille
personnes qui ne seraient pas à jour de
leurs vaccinations alors les faux bien
sûr minimiser ce chiffre un petit peu
puisqu'il ya tout ce qu'ils sont
qui ont été contaminés récemment par le
coc u19 mais qui ne l'ont pas déclaré
sur tous en tic au vide mais on s'attend
qu'il même à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de passes sanitaire désactiver
aujourd'hui et c'est certainement l'une
des allant des motifs de colère des
manifestants aujourd'hui ici à paris
mais également dans toute la france
merci beaucoup dit marc aussi pour
toutes ces précisions en direct x de
cette manifestation